I'm Laura Ingram this is the Ingram
angle from Washington thanks for being
with us on a Friday night
all right last night residents of East
Palestine Ohio finally had their chance
to question the railway responsible for
that crash that sent toxic chemicals
pouring into their soil
after skipping previous events Norfolk
Southern finally sent someone to a town
hall
and even then the CEO didn't have the
decency or the courage to appear
instead they sent some poor lower level
representative to grovel my name is
Daryl Wilson Corporation
[Music]
[Applause]
the contamination that's on site it took
us a number of weeks to figure out where
it is
[Applause]
[Music]
too long
but we are sorry and we do care we care
no it's more like they were forced to
say that they care
and why should the residents feel
reassured at all
it was only last week that Ohio
Lieutenant Governor John husted
suggested that the company should
temporarily or permanently relocate
residents who feel unsafe
the Norfolk representative of course he
wouldn't commit to that has there been
any talk about relocating people
[Music]
what I'm going to State on this on this
topic is right now this will be an
evolving conversation that's going to go
on for quite a while we are going to
make data status-driven decisions okay
imagine living under this cloud of
uncertainty and fear without a credible
voice offering a credible plan it is not
safe in my home I can't sell my home I
have all experienced a symptom
you know you have and then you leave and
it goes away and you come back and it's
here again
I'm being able to live in that we wanted
to hear a game plan tonight from you
guys to say this is where we're going
not three weeks so now I have to wait
another three weeks before anything's
done you haven't said anything about
surface testing you haven't said
anything about testing dioxins in our
home now despite the claims that the
area is safe to be inhabited that the
water is fine to drink and thus
relocation isn't needed disturbing
reports continue to trickle in
nearby health clinics say they're seeing
five to ten new people every day with
symptoms consistent with chemical
exposure
but Norfolk Southern isn't the only
culpable party here from day one the
bind Administration has tried to pass
the buck falsely blaming the Trump
Administration for mixing regulations
that had nothing to do with this crash
and it took the EPA commissioner two
weeks to step foot in East Palestine it
took paternity Pete three weeks to get
there
and as for Biden himself well he was
more comfortable enjoying a photo op
with zelinski in Ukraine
Ohio
[Applause]
I've spoken with every official in Ohio
Democrat and Republican on a continuous
basis as in Pennsylvania I laid out a
little bit in there what I think the
answers are and I will be under it
some point
by the way Ohio democrats they're no
better
Democrat Sherrod Brown who spent last
weekend in California raising cash for
his reelection he's pointed the finger
at Norfolk Southern's corporate lobbyist
for the derailment but okay how does
that help though and by the way Brown
himself has accepted more than 41
thousand dollars from Norfolk Southern
and its lobbyists to his campaign and a
political Affiliated ex-political action
committees since the year 2004.
Now by contrast newly elected Ohio
Senator J.D Vance well he's been the
real deal
on the ground in East Palestine from the
very beginning he has made his
constituents the top priority as it
should be
his new legislation states that rail
carriers would need to create emergency
response plans and provide information
and Advance notification to the
emergency response commissions of each
state a train passes through that's good
stuff
now the train derailment in East
Palestine revealed a lot of things
didn't it the dangerous shortcuts
Corporate America takes to save a buck
the disdain for medical America
especially less affluent white part of
the country and probably more Republican
and perhaps most importantly
it shows us why leaders still matter hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else